Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe gehört, der Bolsonaro hat seine Fußfessel mit einem Lötkolben bearbeitet.
Wer will es ihm verdenken? Das
ist kreativer und kritischer Umgang mit Technik. Das ist Spaß am Gerät.
Musik Musik Musik.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 538 vom 23.11.2025.
Direkt aus dem Zentrum für kreativen Umgang mit Technologie,
wenn es auch nur der Lötkolben an der eigenen Fußfessel ist.
Also es gibt hier ein Foto von, also der hat den Lötkolben an dem Plastikgehäuse angesetzt.
Lötkolben an dem Plastikgehäuse. Ich meine, der hätte erst mal mit dem Dremel anfangen können.
Ja, da müsste man dem nochmal zeigen. Dann muss er nochmal bei uns im Makerspace vorbeikommen.
Dann zeigen wir ihm einfach so ein Ding. Das ist also erste...
Der haben sie jetzt, glaube ich, in so ein Makerspace ist eingewiesen nach dieser Witznation.
Da kann er sich doch ein bisschen mit Metallbearbeitung beschäftigen.
Flucht, Gefahr und Manipulation an Bolzonaros elektronischer Fußfessel. Ja, meine Güte.
Manche Leute haben so das Talent, eine ohnehin schon beschissene Situation durch
besondere Dummheit noch ein bisschen beschissener zu machen.
Da bin ich immer wieder erstaunt. Ich meine, man kennt das auch von sich selber.
Ich meine, da sind wir alle ein bisschen schuldig, so Blödheit kommt.
Aber in seiner Situation weiß ich auch nicht.
Also ich weiß jetzt, so ein technisches Gerät,
das man von seinem Körper nicht trennen kann und das unterm Verdacht steht,
sag ich mal, die eigenen Interessen kontinuierlich in unterschiedlich großem Ausmaß zu verletzen.
Da würde ich auch mal irgendwie versuchen reinzugucken.
Also ich würde den armen Mann da jetzt nicht.
Okay, wir haben Verständnis für seine Neugier.
Ja.
Neugier ist immer eine gute Ausrede.
Ist eine gute Ausrede aus Neugier. Also die Neugier hat den Mann ja zu viel getrieben.
Er hat ja sehr viel aus Neugier getan.
Aber zu viel Neugier kommt dann eben auch Fafo.
Kennst du Fafo? Habe ich schon mal gesagt. Fuck around and find out.
Und da ist jetzt seine Fußfeste.
So viel Neugier hat der Mann gehabt.
Ja, ja. Aus FOMO wird FAFO.
Ja, 23. November heißt auch, ich habe jetzt die goldenen 20er endlich vervollständigt. Nein.
Doch, die sind jetzt komplett. Das war's.
Das musst du erklären.
Und das war CRE?
CRE 001, genau. Chaos Radio Express stellt sich vor.
Und das war noch ein etwas rumpeliger Versuch, in irgendeiner Form mal zu formulieren,
was ich eigentlich vorhabe.
Spoiler, das, was ich da verkündet habe, ist dann so nicht eingetreten,
aber es hat einiges anderes in Bewegung gesetzt.
Und siehe da, 20 Jahre später sitzen wir ja immer noch und machen unsere Witze.
Und die Meta-Ebene als Label kam aber erst später, oder?
Ja, der Name war nicht wirklich jetzt von Anfang an da, aber da ja für mich
der Name eher für das steht, was ich tue, im Kontext des Podcasting,
mit dem schönen Slogan, es gilt das gesprochene Wort.
Das war damit, ja. Ja, das ist irgendwie rückwirkend gültig.
Also für mich ist das sozusagen der Name für das, was ich getan habe,
auch wenn der Name selbst sich jetzt später gefunden hat.
Also der Brand ist jetzt noch nicht 20 Jahre alt, aber die Aktivität ist 20 Jahre alt.
Und man könnte auch argumentieren, dass sie schon 30 Jahre alt ist,
weil ich ziemlich genau 10 Jahre vorher die erste Chaos-Radiosendung mitgemacht habe.
Das war tatsächlich auch im November 1995 und naja, das ist natürlich jetzt
technisch betrachtet kein Podcasting gewesen,
aber das ist ja der Auslöser ein bisschen gewesen, dass ich festgestellt habe,
so der Tim und das Mikrofon,
die können sich gut leiden.
Und dann saß ich da irgendwie zehn Jahre lang und dachte mir immer so vom linken
Arschbacke auf rechte Arschbacke rutschend so, schon gut, aber das Radio,
das drumherum, das stört noch so ein bisschen. und so.
Naja, 95 kann man sich jetzt kaum noch vorstellen, aber da war dann so dieses,
es wäre doch geil, wenn man das im Internet machen könnte, ein nicht wirklich erfüllbarer Wunsch.
Also kaum jemand hatte überhaupt Internet und wenn man da rein wollte,
dann war man noch oft auf Modems angewiesen und naja, Bandbreite war noch nicht mal ein Wort.
Die MP3 hat sich noch nicht so richtig etabliert. Also da waren so viele Dinge
noch völlig unklar, wie man das jetzt eigentlich genau machen soll.
Und vor allem war unklar...
Vielleicht kannst du dich da auch noch dran erinnern, es gab so eine Phantom-Diskussion
im Internet darüber, was ist denn jetzt das richtige Modell, Push oder Pull?
Muss man es den Leuten reindrücken oder holen die es sich selber?
Was ist sozusagen das Abo-Modell? Und da gab es immer viel hin und her und am Ende, muss ich sagen,
war dann eben die Bloggerwelt eigentlich mit ihrem Syndication-Modell mit RSS
dann auf der richtigen Spur.
Und als ich dann so vor 21 Jahren gecheckt habe, so ah, okay,
es gibt jetzt hier irgendwie RSS 2.0 und jetzt haben sie da noch einen Link
auf die Audiodatei gepackt, dann dachte ich mir so, das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Und dann habe ich eigentlich vor 21 Jahren mehr oder weniger schon den Beschluss
gefasst, okay, das Podcasting, das ist irgendwie genau mein Ding.
Aber dann habe ich erst mal geguckt, was ja der richtige Weg sein könnte und
habe erst mal ein Jahr lang Kopfhörer aufgesetzt und mir alles angehört,
was die anderen zu dem Zeitpunkt schon produziert haben.
Dass die Sachen nachher den richtigen Namen bekommen, war ja bei der Freakshow auch so.
Die ist ja auch fünf Jahre lang unter falschen Namen entschieden, bis es sie...
Ja, das war ein Schmerz und ich habe so einen kleinen Blogbeitrag geschrieben,
wo ich das auch nochmal ein bisschen erzähle, über 20 Jahre Meta-Ebene,
könnt ihr mal draufklicken, könnt ihr euch mal durchlesen.
Ja, mir bleibt einfach… Zwei schwierige Jahre.
Ah, die letzten beiden, okay, ich dachte die, ja.
Nicht die ersten. Ja, ich habe so ein bisschen erläutert, dass jetzt irgendwie
so ein bisschen meine Sendefrequenz gelitten hat.
Auf jeden Fall wird sich das jetzt auch bald ändern. Ich habe jetzt wieder ganz
viele neue Raumzeittermine. Also da geht es jetzt bald wieder weiter.
Und überhaupt ist, ja. Manchmal ist es halt nicht so einfach mit dem Sendegeschäft.
Aber wir sind ja auch noch dabei.
Früher waren meine Projekte meistens nach sieben Jahren abgeschlossen.
Podcasts lassen mich nicht müde werden. Ja, schön. Also krass,
ich hatte ja auch über diese Zeiten wahrscheinlich nicht ganz die 20 Jahre.
Bei der ersten CRE war ich glaube ich noch nicht, also die habe ich nachgehört,
weil ich habe alle CREs gehört.
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich zu CRE gefunden habe, es wird nicht ganz 20 Jahre her sein.
Aber hat mich ja auch über all diese Jahre begleitet und irgendwann dazu gebracht,
dass ich selber Teil von dem ganzen Spaß wurde, als wir beide 2011 dann angefangen haben.
Ja, du hast mir irgendwann mal auf einer Party auf dem Balkon erzählt,
dass du irgendwie CRE hörst und das irgendwie ganz geil findest und dann dachte
ich mir so, okay, den Typen, der ganze Sätze sprechen kann, den merke ich mir mal.
Ja, also Respekt Tim, cooles Ding.
Feine Sache. 20 Jahre. Scheiße.
Das ist schon eine Menge Holz.
Über viele Jahre. Naja, ist jetzt die Leute, viele Leute in die Volljährigkeit begleitet.
Eigentlich ein kontinuierliches Bergab in diesen goldenen 20ern.
Ich kriege ja auch vor allem, und das finde ich ja wirklich irgendwie nice,
also ab und zu Leute, jetzt auch in den Kommentaren wieder, aber ich habe das
auch schon ein paar Mal gehabt, so Leute, die mir wirklich erzählen,
dass sie irgendwie keine Ahnung, als wir mit Chaos Radio angefangen haben,
irgendwie zwölf oder so waren.
Und dann so ein bisschen eben dadurch auch so eine Lebensbegleitung in technischer
Hinsicht bekommen haben und dann später so technische Berufe eingeschlagen haben
und mittlerweile jetzt so voll im Berufsleben stehen und so.
Das macht man sich selber manchmal gar nicht so klar, wenn man so eine halböffentliche,
Person ist, was man dann teilweise so für Auswirkungen hat, für die man ja irgendwie,
von denen man ja irgendwie nichts weiß.
Oder bestenfalls vielleicht mal ahnt. Aber ich finde das sehr schön,
solche Geschichten, höre ich gerne.
Weil man natürlich dann auch das Gefühl bekommt, das hat sich auch alles gelohnt und war sowas gut.
Ja, ich denke, das ist ja der,
Der Grund, dass wir es tun, dass es irgendwie einen Impact hat,
wo eine Wirkung entfaltet, ja. Schön, Mensch, freu mich.
Es gibt auch noch andere Leute, die Impact entfalten.
Ja, also ich habe gerade hier die Kommentare unter deinem Blogpost gesehen,
da steht Sperrspitze des deutschen Podcasts, das stimmt natürlich.
Also ich meine, viele haben noch keine Podcasts.
Viele wussten noch nicht, was das ist, als du damit angefangen hast.
Musst man noch zehn Jahre lang erklären.
Ebenfalls habe ich in meinem Podcast-Feed-Empfänger in den letzten Wochen auf
einmal sehr viel einen Gast gesehen, den wir bei uns in der Sendung hatten bei der 500.
Anne Bror-Hilker in vielen Podcasts gerade zu Gast weil ihr Buch veröffentlicht wurde und zwar das.
Moment, Milliarden und Moral ist glaube ich der Titel Cum Ex Milliarden und Moral,
ich habe es tatsächlich schon gehört ich habe das Buch natürlich vorbestellt
und das Hörbuch mir angehört kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Link zu Geniallokal und Amazon und so weiter und einem Interview mit Anne Brohecker
haben wir nochmal auch hier in den Shownotes.
Der Amazon-Link ist ein Affiliate-Link, das heißt, wenn ihr das bestellt,
dann bekomme ich eine klitzekleine Teil davon ab, das muss man ja immer dazu sagen.
Und ich glaube, das empfiehlt sich als Weihnachtsgeschenk, das Buch.
Also ich finde, es hat einerseits natürlich diese gesamte Situation,
was das da überhaupt ist, wird behandelt,
also Cum-Ex und so weiter, dann spricht sie viel, natürlich gibt es viele coole
Anekdoten aus der Ermittlungsarbeit, die sie da geleistet hat mit den vielen,
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zusammen und der Polizei und was da was Besonderes
war und was die Herausforderungen sind in der Ausstattung und so weiter.
Viele, natürlich alles, was sie in der LMP 500 erzählt hat, kommt natürlich
auch drin vor, ist ja klar, weil das waren ja die most noteworthy things,
die sie da schon erzählt hat, das ist halt ein ganzes Buch.
Dann natürlich über die Finanzlobby und ihre Ausstattung, wie es dazu kommt,
dass immer wieder Gesetze entstehen, die so funktionieren und das ermöglichen.
Und auch natürlich eine persönliche Betrachtung ihrer Rolle.
Als Staatsanwältin, als Frau und als introvertierte Person, als sie sich selber bezeichnet.
Ich finde, sie wirkt ja nicht so, aber ist bekennende Introvertierte.
Und behandelt halt auch das so ein bisschen, was quasi die Stärken ihrer...
Also was es ihr ermöglicht hat, Leute besser zu beobachten, länger zuzuhören,
wie das die Ermittlungsarbeit gestärkt hat, unterschätzt zu werden und damit zu arbeiten.
Gleichzeitig natürlich auch eine Reihe an Beleidigungen, die über sie einhergegangen sind.
Spannendes Buch, sehr lesens und oder hörenswert.
Also wenn man sie in unserem Podcast mal gehört hat, dann kann man aber auch
das Gefühl bekommen, dass sie ihren Beruf als Introvertierte dann doch eher verfehlt hat.
Also das war schon ziemlich hilarious. wie es irgendwie, was sie da abgegeben hat.
Sie sagt, dass das für sie stressig ist. Das war ja auch, also es sagt sie,
in den Podcasts, die gerade entstehen, in dem Buch behandelt sie das nochmal
ausführlich, dass das eben ein Thema ist,
introvertiert zu sein. Übrigens nicht als Schwäche, sondern als Stärke natürlich
in der Arbeit, aber dass sie eben diese Öffentlichkeitsarbeit,
das ist für sie eine Belastung.
Kriegt aber auch, ich war bei alles gesagt, war das, wo sie auch so sagt,
ja das setzt sie unter Druck und macht sie irgendwie,
stresst sie oder so und dann sagen auch halt hier der Jochen Wegner und ich
weiß nicht wie der andere da heißt, sagen halt auch so, ja könnten sie jetzt
nicht so feststellen, weil sie es ja enorm gut macht.
Aber es ist ja auch ein inneres Empfinden.
Man wächst mit seinen Aufgaben.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das kann man Da kann Anne Brorhecker nun wirklich ein Lied
von singen, dass sie mit den Aufgaben mitgewachsen ist, die sie sich selber gesetzt hat.
Oder mit ihren eigenen Zielen. Naja, also cooles Buch.
Denke ein sinnvolles Weihnachtsgeschenk in vielen Richtungen,
weil es eben nicht nur ein politisches Buch ist.
Also nicht nur ein strafrechtlich-politisches Buch, sondern eben auch ein sehr...
Auf vielen anderen Dimensionen noch stattfindet, dieses Buch.
Und ja, natürlich bin ich auch sehr, sehr, war ich ja damals schon sehr stolz,
dass wir, glaube ich, der erste Podcast waren, dem die Ehre zuteil wurde,
Frau Brauchelka.
Ja, die haben wir uns erarbeitet.
Die haben wir uns erarbeitet.
Ja.
Das war nicht einfach. Haben wir uns Mühe gegeben. War einer der,
muss ich auch sagen, war wirklich einer der,
coolsten Momente, die so unter die Haut gegangen sind, als sie als du angefangen
hast, sie vorzustellen noch nicht den Namen gesagt hattest und in dem Moment als,
der ganze Saal explodiert sofort der Applaus, das waren so das sind so Dinger,
die gehen unter die Haut absolut,
Alright, hey.
Gucken wir mal zur Sendung.
Oder?
Genau, gucken wir mal zur Sendung, gucken wir mal ins Feedback ausnahmsweise.
Es gab so ein paar Anmerkungen, die sicherlich hier der Erwähnung wert sind.
Beginnt mit einem Nachtrag zum AI-Act.
Jule schreibt, nur eine kurze Nachfrage, Feedback zum Thema AI-Office bei der
Kommission im Monologsegment.
Ich bin etwas verwundert, dass unter anderem ihr und zum Beispiel der Tagesspiegel
jetzt erst auf die zentrale Rolle der Kommission im AI-Act aufmerksam werdet.
Im bereits 2024 in Kraft getretenen Text vom Gesetz steht schon drin,
dass die Kommission tun und lassen darf, was eine Marktüberwachungsbehörde eben tut und lässt.
Wenn ein sogenannter Anbieter ein sogenanntes GPAI-Modell, also General Purpose
AI-Modell baut und da dann auch ein System draus macht und einsetzt,
das steht dort jetzt bereits drin.
Steht zwar in einem Kapitel, das erst ab August 26 gilt, wenn ich den Artikel
am Ende richtig verstanden habe, aber ich sehe nicht wirklich,
worin hier der Omnibus was Neues sagt.
Wenn ich jetzt mal spinne und überlege, welche Konstellation trifft denn diese
Regelung im jetzigen Zustand, dann denke ich zum Beispiel an Google oder Meta,
die eigene Modelle in Systeme pressen.
Hoch, das sind ja gleichzeitig very large online platforms oder very large online search engines.
Das ist aber komisch, dass man nun drunter schreibt, ach ja und die Regeln sollen
auch für diese gelten im Omnibus.
Wo ist hier bitte die Änderung in Bezug auf eine Zentralisierung?
Es war doch vor dem Omnibus schon zentriert.
Sollte man da nicht vielmehr das eigene Gesetz und nicht den Omnibus dafür kritisieren?
Ach ja, aber das AI-Office gibt es ja auch schon.
Die haben ein paar nette Sachen, um sich im AI-Act zurechtzufinden.
Ähm, okay.
Nehmen wir mal so zur Kenntnis.
Wir nehmen das jetzt mal so zur Kenntnis. Ja.
Ich glaube, den Omnibus, das ist ein Thema, wo ich aktuell gerade insbesondere
die Einlassungen von Max Schrems verfolge und None of your business.
Und ich glaube, wir werden uns bemühen, den Max dazu nochmal in der Sendung zu haben.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das schreibe ich mir direkt mal auf und schreibe ihm gleich mal, wann er denn Zeit hat.
So, dann zum Thema Glasfaser. Schreibt uns Glas klar.
Ich halte ja die Argumentation für Glasfaserausbau jetzt sofort nachzuholen,
weil Zukunft für sehr wenig aussagekräftig und tragfähig.
Vielleicht könnte man sich ja mal die Mühe machen und ganz konkrete Bedarfe
der Gesellschaft identifizieren und aufarbeiten, um die Diskussion ein wenig
fachlich anspruchsvoller und zielgerichteter zu führen.
Ja, also wir haben ja darüber geredet und ich glaube, wir implizieren immer
so ein bisschen Glasfaser gut und Kupferböse.
Ja, das implizieren wir, ja.
Das implizieren wir und kann auch nachvollziehen, dass es für manche nicht so
richtig verständlich ist.
Es gab ja auch verschiedene Kommentare mit so, ja, ich habe hier so und so viel
Megabit, das reicht mir auch.
Ich denke, so nebenbei haben wir es aber schon angesprochen,
vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt breit ausgerollt.
Ich meine, es gibt natürlich die Privatanwender, aber es gibt natürlich auch
Small Business, Business, größere Unternehmen etc., die brauchen auch Daten.
Das ist so das eine. Glasfaser hat einfach gegenüber diesen kupferbasierten
Ausrollungen den Vorteil, dass da sehr viel Luft nach oben ist.
In so eine Glasfaser passt das.
Sehr viel Daten rein. Das ist halt einfach eine Eigenschaft dieses Mediums und
es ist natürlich auch etwas, was potenziell einen sehr viel geringeren Ressourcenverbrauch
hat. Das ist so ein Nebenaspekt.
Ich meine, Kupfer ist auch teuer, wird ja auch mal gerne von den Ladesäulen abgeschnitten.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das Hauptproblem. Aber Glasfaser ist halt einfach
die richtige Technologie, die man jetzt nehmen sollte und die vor allem sich
relativ günstig in Überkapazitäten ausrollen lässt.
Niemand würde jetzt unsinnige Überkapazitäten an Kupfer irgendwo hinlegen,
aber Überkapazitäten an Glasfaser sind überhaupt gar kein Problem,
weil die Faser selber ist nicht das Teure,
sondern es ist das Öffnen der Rohre, das Verlegen, das Einmal in den Bodenlegen ist das Teure.
In dem Moment, wo du aber das entsprechend ausrollst und vor allem,
und das war ja auch so ein bisschen Teil unserer Argumentation,
den Staat hier in die Pflicht nimmt.
Seiner Verantwortung für das Bereitstellen von Infrastruktur oder zumindest
das Ermöglichen von Infrastruktur in die Pflicht zu nehmen, dann ist es halt relativ klar,
dass man mit einem vertretbaren Aufwand schon vor langer,
langer Zeit hätte enorme Kapazitäten legen können und die dann einfach der Gesellschaft
und den Unternehmen als existierende Infrastruktur bereitstellen kann.
Das ist etwas, was so jetzt mit anderen Techniken nicht geht. Dass jetzt der einzelne.
Endverbraucher nicht unbedingt unmittelbar von einer Glasfaser profitiert,
weil theoretisch eine existierende alte Kupferleitung das auch bereitstellen kann.
Ja, klar, aber das ist nicht das Argument an dieser Stelle, sondern was ist
in 10 Jahren? Was ist in 20 Jahren?
Was ist, wenn irgendwo jemand sich selbstständig macht und aus welchen Gründen
auch immer, weil er irgendwie streamt oder weil er,
enorme Upload-Kapazitäten Kapazitäten braucht, um diese Dienstleistung überhaupt
anbieten zu können, diesen Bedarf einfach hat, dann kannst du mal nicht eben mal umschalten.
Und deswegen ist es halt einfach erforderlich, eine Infrastruktur zu haben,
wo du sagen kannst, so 8 Gigabit, 10 Gigabit, alles kein Problem,
alles nur eine Frage letzten Endes des Angebots, ja, des Dienstleisters.
Und außerdem ermöglicht eine solche Glasfaser-Infrastruktur theoretisch auch
den Markteintritt von sehr viel mehr Providern.
Also schönes Beispiel immer wieder so Schweden, wo du halt einfach deine Glasfaser
bekommst und dann klickst du dir einfach selber deinen Provider aus einer langen Liste,
die dir dann auf dem Webbrowser angezeigt werden und dann ist das innerhalb
von ein paar Minuten auch alles erledigt.
Und hier ist es einfach ein Megakrampf.
Die Argumente kann man, glaube ich, noch sehr viel weiterführen,
aber ich würde mal sagen, das ist so die Essenz.
Ich würde nur kurz, weil vielleicht die Frage kommt, warum kriegst du mehr in Glasfaser rein?
Du kannst in unterschiedlichen Wellenlängen da durchleuchten,
die sich gegenseitig nicht stören.
Dadurch hast du sehr viel mehr grundsätzliche Möglichkeit, darüber Daten zu
übertragen, während du in Kupfer dann letztendlich auf einem Frequenzband irgendwie
modulieren musst. Und da gibt es dann irgendwann ein Ende.
Du hast viel weniger Verluste. Kupfer, letztendlich sind das Elektronen,
die du in einem Widerstand eines Metalls hin- und herschubst.
Und Licht wird in dem Glas sehr viel weniger abgeschwächt. Das heißt,
du hast weniger Verluste über die langen Strecken.
Gleichzeitig, weil bei Kupfer Elektronen in Metall bewegt werden,
hast du die ganze Anfälligkeit auf elektromagnetische Störungen,
beziehungsweise auch, dass du selber eine Störung bist, eventuell.
Das heißt, Kupfer reagiert auf Funk,
Strom und so weiter, was wiederum die Nutzbarkeit dieses Mediums stark schwächt
und dann hast du am Ende noch eine etwas schnellere Geschwindigkeit,
dadurch, dass du dich hier...
Mit Licht sauber über die Länge, über die Distanz arbeiten kannst,
mit sehr viel klareren, sauberen Signalen, die sich eben dann am Ende auch schneller übertragen lassen.
Das sind so die vier entscheidenden Punkte.
Schneller und vor allem auch noch latenzärmer. Also die Reaktion ist doch mal deutlich geringer.
Und deswegen, ja, es gibt eigentlich nur Vorteile und es ist halt einfach absurd,
dass man das nicht schon lange verfolgt.
Und vor dem Hintergrund, wenn man jetzt gerade zurückblickt,
dass der Tim sagt, vor 20 Jahren oder vor 30 Jahren hat sich noch nicht mal die Frage gestellt,
ob man eine Radiosendung im Internet veröffentlichen kann und heute ist es halt
so, dass Fernsehen darüber gestreamt wird.
Es gibt jetzt eigentlich keinen Grund zu der Annahme, dass der Bedarf an Bandbreite
jetzt in irgendeiner Weise abflachen würde in Zukunft.
Also eventuell von mir aus geht die erste Ableitung ein bisschen runter und
er nimmt nicht mehr ganz so schnell zu, sobald alle Fernsehen gucken können zu Hause.
Aber es ist erkennbar, dass die aktuelle Infrastruktur auf Kupfer.
Einem zukünftigen Bedarf nicht gewachsen sein wird.
Selbst wenn man heute sagt, ich habe heute noch die zehnfache Kapazität von
dem, was ich brauche, ja.
Das hatte ich zum Beispiel mal, als ich Anfang der 2000er DSL mit einem,
oder was war das dann, ein Mbit oder was?
Der hat eine Mbit-Leitung gehabt.
Und haben gesagt, meine Güte, ein Mbit.
Meine Güte.
Oder die Überlegung von 56K-Modem auf 64 oder sogar ISDN-Kanalbündelung 128.
Meine Güte, da kannst du das Internet mit voll machen.
Wir haben das alles schon hinter uns, dass diese heute lächerlich geringen Werte,
die Größenordnungen unter dem heutigen Standardbedarf sind, utopisch erschienen.
Genauso wie es jetzt irgendwie utopisch erscheint, eine Bude mit einem Gigabit
anzubinden, für den größeren Teil, während wir mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
in 20 Jahren sagen werden, da saßen wir in dieser Wohnung mit einem Gigabit.
Da konnten wir gar keine kompletten AI-Roboter unseren Haushalt machen lassen
oder was auch immer wir dann tun.
Der Bedarf der Gesellschaft und der Wirtschaft hat.
An Datenübertragungsmöglichkeiten wird weiter hochgehen.
Und das ist eben etwas, was über den Bedarf der Einzelperson hinausgeht und
ja, etwas mit Zukunftsfähigkeit zu tun hat.
Und auf viele Anwendungen kommt
man ja auch erst, wenn man sozusagen diese Ressourcen zur Verfügung hat.
Weil dann kann man ja überhaupt erst damit rumprobieren, wenn du gar keine Möglichkeit
hast, in irgendeiner Form deine Bandbreite zu steigern.
Also wir haben heutzutage in der Regel asymmetrisches, DSL.
Das heißt, dein Upload ist nochmal deutlich geringer, teilweise absurd viel
geringer als dein Download.
Klar kann man dann argumentieren, ja, wieso mein Netflix kommt ja schnell genug
und zum Streamen reicht das ja, aber du willst ja dann, was weiß ich,
hast ein Unternehmen mit 20 Leuten und dann wollen die 20 Leute alle gleichzeitig Zoom machen,
Und auf einmal hast du irgendwie 20 Videostreams, die in die andere Richtung
gehen und dann hängt aber alles richtig und nicht nur, dass das dann irgendwie
in die Richtung nicht schnell genug geht,
du verstopfst dann auch noch schnell deine asymmetrische Leitung,
die dann irgendwie damit nicht klarkommt und dann sind deine Downloads auch noch im Arsch.
Also das ist halt einfach alles Quatsch und man muss einfach mit mehr Luft nach oben arbeiten.
Es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Grund, warum nicht einfach jeder einen Gigabit-Anschluss
dann letzten Endes über Glasfaser bekommen soll. Und dann, okay,
dann benutzt du es vielleicht alles meistens nicht.
Stört aber nicht. Die Glasfaser ist immer noch dieselbe. Du musst nicht dafür
mehr Glas in den Boden legen für dieses Gigabit.
Es ist halt einfach nur, dass du es hast, wenn du es brauchst.
Um das mal mit Wir müssen das Thema mit einer Autometapher abschließen Damit.
Die Leute das verstehen in.
Deutschland Ihr wollt alle ein AMG G-Modell mit 600 PS haben,
ihr nutzt ja die 600 PS auch nur an jeder Ampel,
um einmal auf 70 kmh zu beschleunigen und ruft nicht die ganze Zeit,
oder wie viel PS diese Autos haben das ruft ihr ja nicht die ganze Zeit ab Trotzdem
kauft ihr diese Autos und steht dann am Ende mit denen im Stau.
Trotzdem würdet ihr, wenn man sagen würde, wieso, reicht doch,
nimm doch hier so eine Renault Zoe mit, da kommst du genau so an,
würde niemand sagen, brauche ich nicht.
Genau. Also wenn Reichweitenangst ein Ding ist, dann sollte auch Bandbreitenangst ein Thema sein.
Definitiv.
So, Max weist uns noch darauf hin.
Linus, beziehungsweise dich Linus, nach heutiger Erkenntnis war Napoleon nicht
klein, sondern wird wahrscheinlich 1,68 Meter für die damalige Zeit durchschnittlich groß.
Ja, hat er halt drunter gelitten, nur durchschnittlich zu sein.
Ich bin ja froh, dass das der einzige korrigierbare Fehler offenbar war,
den wir in dem ganzen Segment hatten, mit dem Diaphragma von Marie Antoinette und was kann ich alles.
Ich glaube, da haben wir uns ganz gut geschlagen.
Das stimmt. Ganz gut geschlagen hat sich bisher auch Cloudflare,
das Unternehmen, was so ein bisschen der Schutzpatron aller Webseiten im Internet ist.
Wer von Cloudflare noch nichts gehört hat.
Irgendwann ist sicherlich mal beim Abruf irgendeiner Webseite so eine Zwischenwebseite aufgetaucht,
wo so ein paar Wölkchen drauf sind und kurz jemand mal überprüfen musste,
dass du kein Roboter bist oder vielleicht war auch irgendeine Webseite nicht
erreichbar und man sah dann so einen Statusbildschirm von eben dem Unternehmen Cloudfair,
wo drauf stand so, oh ja, die Webseite ist gerade nicht zu erreichen.
Oder macht man ein Capture?
Oder die Webseite ist gerade unter Attacke und vorübergehend gesperrt, all so eine Sachen.
Cloudflare wird gerne genommen, um eben solche Probleme zu lösen und ist für
viele auch wirklich eine Hilfe.
Insofern ist das, wenn man jetzt, keine Ahnung, unter irgendeiner Cyberattacke
steht, dann läuft das einfach durch Cloudflare,
bevor es zu deiner Webseite kommt und die können halt mit ihren Detection-Tools
und entsprechenden Maßnahmen das Schlimmste vielleicht erstmal verhindern oder
vielleicht sogar auch alles verhindern.
Und haben auch viele andere Dienstleistungen, die damit verbunden sind,
ich kann die gar nicht alle aufzählen.
Ja, aber jetzt hatten wir in der letzten Sendung.
Wo wir In der letzten Sendung haben wir über den AWS-Ausfall gesprochen.
Und deswegen, ich glaube, ich würde gerne einmal noch ganz kurz die Gelegenheit
nutzen, ganz schnell den Unterschied zwischen, was macht AWS besonders und was
macht Cloudflare besonders.
Also was haben die AWS sagt, wir haben Infrastruktur, die man in Containern
und so weiter und VMs und so weiter skalieren kann.
Das heißt, ihr braucht keinen eigenen Server mehr, ihr könnt die bei uns kriegen.
Cloudflare sagt, ihr habt Server, ist auch in Ordnung, aber die Server,
die ihr da betreibt, die haben eine Grenze ihrer Kapazität.
Und eines der größten Probleme, die du haben oder eines der häufigsten Probleme,
die du haben kannst, sind irgendwie Kapazitätsprobleme, insbesondere wenn jemand
eine Denial-of-Service auf dich fährt.
Und Cloudflare betreibt im Prinzip Proxyserver, die davor sind,
die Caching betreiben und in der Lage sind, Lasten zu managen.
Das heißt, dein Setup, wenn du sagst, du baust eine Webseite,
die über Cloudflare zugänglich ist,
dann setzt du den DNS-Eintrag auf ein Cloudflare-IP und dein tatsächlicher Server,
den konfigurierst du sinnvollerweise so, dass er nur Cloudflare antwortet.
Das heißt, auf deinem Server, den du irgendwo im Internet stehen hast,
der kriegt die ganze Zeit eigentlich immer nur Anfragen von diesem Cloudflare-Proxy.
Und Cloudflare stellt sich dann hin und verteilt deine Webseite.
Jetzt kommt der erste Zugriff, dann frag Cloudflare einmal bei deinem Server
an und sag, gib mal bitte die Seite.
Dein Server antwortet, dann kommt der nächste, kommt der nächste, kommt der nächste.
Und je nachdem, wie die Last ist, wird Cloudflare anfangen, das einfach dann
aus dem RAM zu bedienen und deinen Server gar nicht mehr damit zu belasten, dass da Leute sind.
Insbesondere dann vor allem auch die statischen Inhalte, die,
die sich nicht ändern, wird Cloudflare einfach dynamisch im RAM halten und so
ein bisschen abfeiern und dein Server wird damit nicht mehr belastet, dass,
alle 100 Besucher das große Bild auf der Startseite haben wollen.
So, jetzt fängt irgendwann, dann gibt es die nächste Möglichkeit,
den Nile-of-Service zu machen, wäre du hast.
Und vielleicht eine dynamische Webseite, ein einfaches Beispiel wäre so eine
Suchfunktion und eine Möglichkeit deinen Server zu überlasten wäre,
ich gebe dem einfach ganz viele unterschiedliche Suchanfragen,
weil dann muss er jedes Mal in der Datenbank Webseiten, in der Datenbank suchen,
eine Antwort generieren und quasi die Antwort ist teurer, weil die Antwort individuell
aufgrund einer Rechenoperation konfiguriert wird.
Und das wiederum, das wird Cloudflare erst mal durchgeben, weil es den Inhalt
ja nicht kennt, muss es deinen Server fragen.
Wenn das zu viel wird, werden sie anfangen zu erkennen, alles klar,
das macht einer oder mehrere, die geben sich hier gerade Mühe,
die wollen uns überlasten, jetzt fange ich mal an, die auszublockieren.
Und ich werde dem einfach nicht mehr antworten.
Und dieses kluge, was heißt klug, aber sagen wir mal überhaupt,
in irgendeiner Weise, individualisierte Balancing,
Erkennen von Angriffen, Erkennen von Denial of Service, das ist das,
was Cloudflare als Service verkauft.
Dann könntest du beispielsweise, wenn jetzt irgendwie Denial of Service auf deinen,
Pizzalieferanten-Webseite läuft, dann könntest du halt irgendwann sagen,
naja, okay, komm, dann schließ einfach mal alle nichtdeutschen IP-Adressen aus,
weil wir liefern eh nur nach Berlin unsere Pizza.
Und dann kannst du dadurch Denial-of-Service-Angriffe auf deine Server relativ gut wegmanagen.
Und dann haben sie noch irgendwelche extra Dinger wie, dass sie Exploits und
diesen ganzen Kram. Und das haben die geschafft zu einem...
Geschäftsmodell auszubauen, das ja, also auch natürlich sehr klug ist.
Und sehr erfolgreich ist und gefühlt 20% aller Webseiten im Netz sind halt hinter Cloudflare,
das nenne ich mal eine Customer Base und dementsprechend ist wie Amazon AWS
auch Cloudflare so eine absolut wichtige Infrastruktur,
die mal idealerweise nicht ausfallen sollte.
Und genau Das ist jetzt passiert. Und es war, wie man vielleicht nicht gleich vermuten würde,
nicht eine Cyberattacke und es wurde jetzt von irgendwas runter gemacht,
sondern ähnlich wie bei Amazon im Übrigen, einfach ein Konfigurationsfehler im System.
Okay, im Prinzip eine Kleinigkeit, da wurde also irgendwo eine Datenbankabfrage
gemacht und die war dann nicht im SQL nicht ausreichend beschränkt und durch
so einen Edge Case kamen dann auf einmal sehr viel mehr Daten aus dieser Datenabfrage
raus, als das normalerweise der Fall ist.
Das wurde dann in so eine Feature-Datei geschrieben, wo irgendwie drin steht.
Wie denn jetzt das Routing in diesem komplexen Netzwerk so abzulaufen hat.
Aber diese Datei wurde dann auf einmal sehr groß, was vielleicht erstmal noch
nicht unbedingt ein Problem ist, solange die Informationen als solche richtig sind.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, ob sie das waren, aber es scheiterte in
dem Moment schon vorher, weil an anderen Stellen, wo dann mit dieser Feature-Datei
gearbeitet werden soll, ja so arbiträre Größenbeschränkungen drin waren.
Wenn die Datei größer ist als so und so viel Bytes, dann Hände hoch und ich
mache hier mal gar nichts.
Und genau das wurde eben durch diesen ursprünglichen Fehler getriggert und das führte dann eben dazu,
dass die ganze Kaskade von Routing-Konfigurationen und wo sollen denn jetzt
welche Anfragen hingehen, komplett zusammengefallen sind und auf einmal war
überhaupt nichts mehr zu erreichen.
Und ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, diese Feature-Datei ist
im Prinzip das Bot-Management-System.
Also das sind genau die Regeln, wo sie ja zum Beispiel sagen,
diese IP-Adressen, denen antworten wir sowieso nicht.
Oder ich glaube, wenn du von einer Tor-Adresse kommst, kriegst du immer erstmal
ein Capture und so weiter.
Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, waren das eben die Konfigurationen des Tages.
Den Kunden ist es am Ende natürlich egal, was jetzt der Grund war,
aber auf einmal sind halt alle ihre Webseiten nicht mehr zu erreichen und wir
wissen ja, was das heutzutage bedeutet.
Online-Shops verdienen da viel Geld mit jeder Stunde, die sie online sind und
verlieren entsprechend viel Geld, wenn sie offline sind. Jetzt hier Black Friday und so weiter.
Das ist jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, eine kaufaktive Zeit.
Definitiv kein Ding. Man muss jetzt sagen, dass Cloudflare verhältnismäßig professionell
auf diesen Ausfall reagiert hat.
Nicht nur, weil sie das dann auch relativ schnell wieder in den Griff bekommen
haben, sondern weil sie auch binnen eines Tages in der Lage waren,
da einen ausführlichen Blogpost zuzuschreiben, in dem sie auch nicht groß rumgeredet
haben, sondern einfach gesagt haben, ja hier scheiß gelaufen, das war das Problem.
Und dann so bis hin zu SQL-Source-Code irgendwie im Blogpost,
so ja genau das hier war der Fehler und das haben wir jetzt geändert und mehr
Kulpa und jetzt werden wir natürlich tausend Sicherungssysteme einbauen,
damit das auf gar keinen Fall jemals wieder passiert.
Für uns ist natürlich das jetzt vom Ausfall her weniger interessant als Anlass,
die Diskussion, die wir schon rund um AWS hatten, da vorzuführen.
Wir haben es in zunehmendem Maße eben mit Akteuren im Internet zu tun,
die jetzt die modernen Probleme mitigieren, wie zum Beispiel diese Denial-of-Service-Attacken
oder generelle Überlastung von Webseiten,
weil das Internet selber mit seinem Protokoll und seiner Struktur an der Stelle funktioniert.
Herzlich wenig zu bieten hat. Also es gibt sozusagen solche Mechanismen jetzt
nicht als Teil der Netzwerkinfrastruktur als solchen,
also das IP-Protokoll und alles, was drumherum sicherstellt,
dass das Web funktioniert, ist im Wesentlichen optimistisch ausgelegt.
Also es ermöglicht immer alles, weil darum geht es, aber es sieht eben diese
ganzen Failure-Modus und Angriffsszenarien und Bad Actors so jetzt im Design
nicht vor, sondern erlaubt erstmal alles.
Und deswegen braucht man diese anderen Infrastrukturen, um da was zu machen
und da jetzt nicht jeder bereit ist, das Engineering da reinzustecken und das
Geld da reinzustecken oder auch gar nicht die Möglichkeit hat, das zu tun,
um sich entsprechend vor diesen Risiken zu schützen,
geht man dann eben auf solche Provider, die dann eben sehr schnell sehr groß
werden, weil die natürlich dann das ganze Talent akquirieren und dann hat man
da auch so einen Netzwerkeffekt so mit, naja, geh doch einfach zu Cloudflare, dann läuft das schon.
Und dann ist es natürlich schwierig, wenn jemand dieses kleine Stückchen da
im Internetgebäude wegtritt und alles wieder zusammenfällt im ganzen Internet-Yanga,
was wir hier die ganze Zeit spielen.
Ja, jetzt ist es natürlich auch nochmal besonders schade, weil Cloudflare natürlich den,
also jetzt auf ihrer Webseite, natürlich die müssen jetzt auch gerade weiterentwickeln,
da stehen natürlich jetzt AI, aber eigentlich gehst du zu Cloudflare,
damit deine Webseite immer erreichbar ist.
Und es ist natürlich schon ein bisschen schade, wenn das dann ausfällt.
Ja.
Da könnte man fast sagen, da bräuchte man ein eigenes Cloud-Fair,
europäisches Cloud-Fair, auch eine Alternative.
Meinst du, um ein bisschen souveräner zu werden in der Hinsicht?
Für Digital könnte man mal ein Gipfel machen.
Ja, rein zufällig fand das ja auch gerade statt, wir hatten das glaube ich auch
schon angekündigt, es gab den Souveränitäts-Digital-Gipfel.
Der eigentlich mehr so eine ja deutsch-französische,
Business Show war weil man kam dann zwar einen ganzen Tag zusammen in Berlin
und hat halt dann diesen Gipfel abgefeiert, der im Wesentlichen dann so aus
Reden besteht und nebenbei,
ja, tut man dann so als hätte man irgendwas,
beschlossen und ja, es wurde, sagen wir mal,
nicht viel davon erwartet von diesem Gipfel und in der Hinsicht war es,
glaube ich, auch ein voller Erfolg.
Es ist, also immerhin war Frankreich da,
Aber immerhin scheinen sie die Problemstellung erkannt zu haben jetzt nach so 20 Jahren oder was, ne?
Man muss sich ja, also was ist jetzt überhaupt, also dieser gesamte Begriff
der Souveränität muss, glaube ich, nochmal einmal getrennt werden,
zumindest von dem Begriff der Autarkie, ja,
also niemand in dieser digitalen Welt ist autark, man hat die Abhängigkeiten,
Hardware kommt aus China, Software kommt aus den USA, ja, dann kann man irgendwie
sagen, okay, aber dann gibt es SAP,
die verteilen dahin und in China könnte man auch die Hardware nicht bauen ohne
ASML und die bauen in Niederlanden die Belichtungsmaschinen für die Wafer,
die in China und so weiter.
Das heißt, da gibt es natürlich gegenseitige Abhängigkeiten und Souveränität
wird dann so ein bisschen so, könnte man sagen, immerhin sind die Abhängigkeiten
vielleicht in einem Gleichgewicht.
So würde ich jetzt mal versuchen.
Diesen Begriff der Digitalisierung. Im besten Fall sind sie in einem Gleichgewicht,
aber es gibt auch gegenläufige Abhängigkeiten, nicht nur in die eine Richtung.
Genau, also in irgendeiner Weise hast du auch einen Hebel.
Und da könnte man.
Glaube ich, wird man jetzt niemandem zu nahe treten, wenn man sagt,
da ist Europa jetzt gerade nicht nicht unbedingt am oberen Ende,
sondern eben in einer relativ starken Abhängigkeit von anderen.
Und da wollen sie jetzt irgendwie was klären.
Das ist vor allem natürlich eine politische Frage, das ist aber auch eine wirtschaftliche Frage.
Und damit ist in meinen Augen vor allem eine wirtschaftspolitische Frage.
Und dafür müsste man sich natürlich erst mal fragen, wie sind wir denn eigentlich hier hingekommen?
Und ich habe jetzt mal so als Beispiel nehmen wir jetzt mal,
Huawei, als Hardware von China, die in unseren wichtigen Infrastrukturen sich befindet.
Was ist passiert? Huawei hat über viele,
viele Jahre völlig problemlos die überlegenen Netzwerkausrüstungsprodukte zu
einem sehr günstigen Preis verkauft.
Das heißt, sowohl in der Qualität als auch im Preis konnten die europäischen
Hersteller nicht mit Huawei konkurrieren.
Und deswegen sind die Mobilfunknetze in Deutschland und nicht nur in Deutschland,
sondern überall mit diesen Komponenten gebaut worden, weil sie nicht nur die
billigeren waren, sondern auch noch die besseren.
Und an diesem Punkt kommst du ja als produzierendes Unternehmen nicht.
Ohne, dass du das halt gezielt dahin willst.
Und genauso ist es ja in den USA. Die US-Services, sei es jetzt AWS oder sonst
was, die haben ja ruinöse Wettbewerbe mit anderen geführt.
Dass jetzt beispielsweise ein Amazon marktdominierend ist, AWS marktdominierend ist,
Microsoft marktdominierend ist, Facebook,
Meta und so weiter, die haben mit unglaublich viel Geld sich diese Positionen
erkämpft und zwar in einem kapitalistischen Umfeld.
Ja und also quasi andere verdrängt,
um die in Anführungszeichen günstigste beste Dienstleistung für eine Zeit lang
anzubieten, um sich aller Konkurrenz zu entledigen und dafür brauchst du halt einen langen Atem.
Das, glaube ich, muss man erstmal, denke ich, zur Kenntnis nehmen,
dass es notwendig oder dass es in diesen Fällen immer auch war,
dass sie die beste Möglichkeit am billigsten angeboten haben.
Und das haben sie ja irgendwann nicht von Anfang an gekonnt.
Das heißt, da wurde investiert in diese Vorherrschaft.
Oder? Du guckst jetzt so kritisch?
Nö, alles gut. Ich lausche deine Ausführungen mit Interesse.
Und jetzt haben wir eine Situation, wir haben irgendwo zwischen 10 und 20 Jahren
Rückschritt, die jetzt konstatiert werden, je nach Technologiebereich.
Und dann fragst du dich, naja, okay, jetzt musst du ja erstmal,
wenn du jetzt sagst, du willst irgendwie in Richtung Souveränität dich bewegen,
dann musst du ja erstmal diese 20 Jahre Rückschritt aufholen.
Nur wenn du das jetzt machst, In der Zeit haben sich die anderen ja auch weiterentwickelt.
Und dieser Fortschritt, würde ich sagen, der Fortschritt wächst jetzt exponentiell
weiter aufgrund der Position, die du jetzt schon hast.
Das heißt, angenommen, wir würden 20 Jahre Rückschritt in 10 Jahren aufholen,
dann werden in den nächsten 10 Jahren die anderen aber auch 10 Jahre weiter sein.
Und dieser Abstand wird noch mal größer sein. Das heißt, selbst wenn wir jetzt
die 20 Jahre in 10 Jahren aufholen, sind wir wahrscheinlich immer noch 20 Jahre
hinterher, Weil die anderen in den 10 Jahren 20 Jahre weitergegangen sind.
Das heißt, wir müssen eigentlich ein exponentielles Aufholen haben.
Und das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das funktionieren soll,
ohne eine massive Investition, also Förderung,
Subvention und natürlich auch eine Bevorteiligung der europäischen Produkte.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass die anderen in diese Position gekommen sind.
Huawei ist doch, das Ding ist halt unglaublich subventioniert gewesen.
Und die USA machen ja gerade, du siehst ja, dass sie auch damit arbeiten.
Die USA mit ihren ganzen Zöller, Zölle, Mager und so weiter,
die führen ja eine aktive,
kann man jetzt beurteilen, wie man will, ich habe ja wenig Ahnung von,
aber mit ganz klar Steuern,
die sehr gezielt mit diesen Zöllen die Abhängigkeiten anderer Marktwirtschaften von sich.
Und Trump geht hin und sagt, pass auf, ihr kriegt hier zu viel,
ihr kauft nicht genug von unseren Bananen, deswegen gibt es jetzt 400% Zoll
auf Euro, ich nehme jetzt irgendwelche Beispiele und damit schützt er dann,
quasi versucht er,
vorzuführen, dass er irgendwie die lokale Produktion schützt,
aber vor allem natürlich die wirtschaftlichen Interessen der USA.
Also ich glaube Bananen sind jetzt nicht so das Exportprodukt der USA.
Ich wollte nur verzeigen, das ist ja auch ein Bündnis. Eben,
dass du nämlich auch eine total bescheuerte Argumentation da vortragen kannst,
wenn du Donald Trump bist.
Und gleichermaßen, sobald die Europäische Union auch nur irgendwie in die Nähe
eines Satzes kommt, der irgendwie in Richtung Digitalsteuer oder sowas gehen könnte,
hat der Donald Trump seinen Sharpie in der Hand und schreibt irgendeine astronomische
Zahl drauf, wie er, was weiß ich, Automobilimporte und so weiter aus Europa
oder Deutschland, wenn das alles quasi ruinieren will.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, diese Regierungen, China, USA, die arbeiten strategisch
und gezielt mit den Abhängigkeiten.
Übrigens auch Russland, dass Deutschland sich da irgendwie über Jahrzehnte in
diese Gasabhängigkeit hat bewegen lassen,
ist ja etwas, was Russland am Ende, oder was heißt am Ende, wir weiß ja nicht,
ob das Ende ist, aber immer mehr in einen Hebel übersetzt hat.
Der Abhängigkeit und diesen auch nutzt.
Und in diesem Feld bewegen wir uns, ob wir wollen oder nicht,
mit Europa und dem europäischen Binnenmarkt, der versucht,
durch seine DMA und DSA irgendwie dem gegenüber noch europäische Werte durchzusetzen.
Und jetzt aber feststellt so, naja, okay, wäre vielleicht gar nicht so blöd,
wenn wir auch europäische Produkte hätten.
Und jetzt sagen sie, wir brauchen die, jetzt kommt der Macron und der Merz und
der Wildberger und sagen, ja, ja, europäische Souveränität, gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm.
Und dann sagen sie, wir machen nämlich jetzt hier eine Digital Commons,
European Digital Infrastructure Consortium, EDIC.
Das wird jetzt das Ökosystem für Open Source Lösungen für die Verwaltung.
Und da sitzen dann Deutschland, Frankreich, Italien und Niederlande,
sagen, wir machen das jetzt und was hat der deutsche Haushalt?
Da haben sie jetzt 450.000 Euro im Haushalt für. Junge, Junge,
da kann ja Microsoft jetzt einpacken.
Da müssen die wahrscheinlich fünf Minuten für arbeiten für so viel Geld.
Ich sehe den Satya Nadella da jetzt schon vor seinem Board. der ist erledigt.
Zittert.
Ja, also was wirklich sehr beunruhigend war, sind natürlich dann auch wieder so diese Aussagen.
Also auf der einen Seite schwang in diesen ganzen Reden von Merz immer dieses,
ja, es ist ja die Regulierung, die uns aufhält.
Es ist ja so diese ganzen Beschränkungen, die wir uns jetzt hier selber setzen,
das hält ja nur die Wirtschaft auf und man darf ja jetzt die Wirtschaft nicht aufhalten.
Also es mag Regulierungen geben, die eine wirtschaftliche Entwicklung aufhalten, gar keine Frage,
da kann man drüber diskutieren, aber was halt dann auch wieder so das Hype-Gredo
der Stunde war, das geht ja auch alles jetzt nur mit AI, also wo man sich wirklich fragen kann, Leute,
Nehmt ihr eigentlich, also schaltet ihr das Hirn eigentlich auch noch mit ein,
während ihr darüber redet oder ist das jetzt einfach wirklich nur noch so Sprechapparat
und Copy und Paste, was gerade der Hype ist und das schmeißt ihr einfach mal
raus. Danach riecht es einfach sehr.
Ja, AI mag irgendwie seine Bedeutung haben. Wir haben ja jetzt hier auch schon
viel darüber diskutiert und es ist sicherlich ein Disruptor und ein Player,
aber es ist jetzt mitnichten unser größtes Problem.
Ja, unser größtes Problem ist Betriebssystemabhängigkeiten, Softwareabhängigkeiten,
Cloudabhängigkeiten, Office, Word, Excel-Abhängigkeiten.
Ja, wenn europäische Richter… in Konsequenz dessen noch nicht mal mehr die Daten
bei uns haben, mit denen wir irgendeine AI trainieren können.
Ich meine, dadurch, dass unsere Sachen alle in irgendeiner US-Cloud liegen,
wer wird denn jetzt mit unseren Daten seine AIs trainieren?
Ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall sehr,
Das ist eine simple Argumentation, man müsste ja jetzt hier irgendwie mit dem
Angriff von AI wird alles in Ordnung kommen.
Das ist im Wesentlichen das, was da gesagt wird.
Das ist natürlich totaler Unsinn. Und wenn du richtig darauf hinweist,
dass wir sozusagen da 10, 20 Jahre Rückstand haben und jetzt ein exponentielles
Wachstum entfalten müssen in dieser Innovationsfreude,
um überhaupt erstmal eine Produktbasis zu schaffen,
dann kann man halt jetzt nicht alle seine Eier in einen Korb legen,
sondern da muss man natürlich breit streuen.
Und man muss alle Möglichkeiten nutzen und da sind wir eigentlich auch schon
wieder bei dieser Ursprungsdiskussion um Infrastruktur.
Man muss Entwicklung ermöglichen und da jetzt, gut, Open Source haben sie gesagt,
also wenn sie jetzt da ihr Digital Infrastructure Konsortium haben,
aber es ist halt für 450.000 Euro absehbar, dass da nicht viel läuft.
Ja, also die Zivilgesellschaft war ja bei diesem ganzen Digitalgipfel überhaupt nicht vertreten.
Und es ist insofern ein bisschen absurd,
als dass wir gerade in Deutschland ja
auch tatsächlich speziell im zivilgesellschaftlichen Bereich eine enorme,
also in diesem digital zivilgesellschaftlichen Bereich absolute Erfolgsmeldungen
haben seit Jahrzehnten.
Es gibt kaum ein Land wie Deutschland, wo,
zum Beispiel diese Wikipedia so eine starke Community ist.
Es gibt kaum ein Land, wo diese Linux-Bewegung und Open-Source-Bewegung so stark
ist, wie in Deutschland.
Da ist ausnahmsweise Deutschland mal wirklich auch führend.
Also jetzt nicht führend für die ganze Welt.
Aber nicht so wie früher.
Aber es ist nicht so, ja, machen wir auch noch ein bisschen und ich habe mal
hier so einen Rechner installiert, sondern es kommt sehr für Entwicklungen daraus.
Das ist einfach traditionell sehr stark und niemand setzt drauf auf diese Stärken.
Dabei, ja, es ist jetzt nicht gesagt, dass das jetzt für alles die Lösung bringen
wird. Ich stelle mich jetzt hier nicht hin und sage,
dann braucht ihr nur Linux nehmen und dann geht das schon. So einfach ist die
Sache jetzt nicht. Aber das Potenzial ist ja da.
Musst du schon noch den können, Kumpel.
Ja, das Ding ist, ja, aber...
Die Kompetenz ist da, ja. Die Kompetenz ist da.
Ja, aber du kannst halt nicht freie Software entwickeln und dann auch einfach
mal einen gemeinnützigen Verein dafür gründen, weil das einfach nicht als gemeinnützig
anerkannt wird, weil das einfach generell ausgeschlossen ist,
weil geht ja nicht, wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Das ist für Fußballvereine reserviert und vielleicht noch für alte Autos pflegen,
aber halt nicht für irgendwie die Zukunft.
Und das sind alles solche Dinge, über die man mal diskutieren müsste und dazu
muss auch die Diskussion breiter geführt werden und nicht halt immer in so Gipfelsituationen,
wo man dann irgendwie immer das Hypewort du jour rausruft und glaubt,
das wird dann schon irgendwie alles richtig werden.
Was ich dann noch sehr unterhaltsam finde, ist, dann stellen sich alle hin und
sagen, hier wird zu viel reguliert. Also,
Zwei Sachen dazu. Ja, wird. Es gibt in Deutschland allein irgendwie zu,
glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung ja auch darüber gesprochen,
weiß ich nicht, wie viele IT-Sicherheitsgesetze auf wie vielen Ebenen wir jetzt
haben, dann in den europäischen Binnenmarkt mit 27 Ländern prügeln wollen.
Das heißt, diese gesamte Idee des europäischen Binnenmarktes mit seinen 27 Teilnehmenden,
die alle ihre eigenen Suppen kochen, das ist natürlich eine Unterlegenheit gegenüber den USA,
die einen einheitlichen Markt schon mal da haben mit einer relativ starken Wirtschaftskraft.
Oder China, die einen Wachstumsmarkt und eine wachsende Gesellschaft haben von
irgendwie Milliarden Leuten und da einheitliche Bedingungen schaffen.
Indien, 1,3 Milliarden Leute oder was das dann sind.
Die haben andere schon allein in ihren lokalen Märkten ganz andere Skaleneffekte.
Insofern ist das schon verständlich, dass man sagt, okay, wir müssen Regulierungshindernisse
innerhalb Europas abbauen.
Wovon die aber reden ist, wir bauen Regulierungshindernisse für diesen ganzen
Technologie-Wirtschaftsmarktbereich ab.
Wer wird denn davon profitieren? Die europäische Wirtschaft,
die es gar nicht gibt oder die USA, die das sehr gerne wegsnacken,
wenn sie jetzt nicht reguliert sind oder weniger Regulierungshindernisse haben.
Das heißt, du musst, wenn du das aufholen willst, so oder so in eine Art Protektionismus
gehen. Du musst halt sagen, okay, wir werden...
Hier jetzt die europäischen Werte, Grundrechte, Ideale und Ideen in Regulierung kippen.
Und wir werden dafür sorgen, dass unsere lokale Wirtschaft das Potenzial hat, die zu erfüllen.
Und wir fördern, dass Leute nach unseren Werten und unseren Vorgaben und Ideen etwas machen,
was für andere werden diese Dinge ein Hemmnis sein. Das ist das, was du tun kannst.
Und was machen wir stattdessen? Stattdessen, also das heißt,
du nimmst die europäischen Werte, übersetzt sie in eine harte Regulierung und
übersetzt sie in Produkte, die diesen Werten entsprechen.
Und dann förderst du diese Produkte und schaffst potenziell,
wenn du Glück hast, ein Modell, das eventuell auch andere überzeugt.
Und wenn nicht, hast du wenigstens was für dich selber. Stattdessen,
nur mal so, wenn du jetzt aus dem Ding rauszoomst, sagen sie,
ja, ja, hier europäische Werte.
Übrigens, wir machen jetzt mal KI-Überwachung, haben wir uns überlegt, mit Chat-Kontrolle.
Und dann wollen wir übrigens auch für die Polizeibehörden, wollen wir das auch
haben. Deswegen kaufen wir ein paar Land hier.
Und dann deregulieren wir den Markt für die USA. Ich verstehe gerade noch nicht
genau, wo da jetzt dieser Souveränitätsgedanke, wo der da verfolgt wird.
Mir fehlt da wahrscheinlich der schöpferische Weitblick von Friedrich Merz,
dem alten Digitalmeister da.
Aber da ist halt keinerlei Strategie erkennbar. Und dann.
Wir haben ja vor vier Jahren Adriana Groh und Katharina Mayer zu Gast gehabt
und haben uns irgendwie über die Machbarkeitsstudie des Sovereign Tech Funds,
zu dem es ja dann später auch kam, unterhalten.
Und da waren im Prinzip diese ganzen Diskussionen ja schon Teil davon.
Also das Ziel hier, eigene Souveränität aufzuziehen, Open Source zu fördern etc.
Vier verlorene Jahre kann man sagen, da ist jetzt nicht zu spüren gewesen,
dass sich das in der Politik großraum erarbeitet hat.
Und wir reden hier halt wirklich von also die Investitionsvolumina und es sind
ja Größenordnungen, das geht ja nicht um irgendwie 54.000 Euro oder so,
und man steht daneben und will schreien weil man auch denkt so was redet ihr was,
aber AI ja mit AI machen. Genau, jetzt kommt AI.
Ja.
Los, weitermachen.
Ja, Chatkontrolle gibt es wieder. Updates, jetzt wollen sie glaube ich am,
also der wahrscheinlich endgültige Gesetzentwurf des Rates ist jetzt irgendwie
gerade so bald halb fertig.
Sie haben nochmal extra reingeschrieben, keine Bestimmung dieser Verordnung
ist so auszulegen, dass sie den Anbietern Aufdeckungspflichten auferlegt.
Das heißt, sie sagen also ganz spezifisch keine verpflichtende Chatkontrolle.
Das hatte ich in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt. Aber das in einer Welt,
in der Chatkontrolle sowieso aktuell verboten ist.
Alle zivilgesellschaftlichen Leute, Wissenschaftler und so weiter sich dagegen
wenden und in dem Ding die Idee dieser Altersprüfung trotzdem drin bleibt.
Also diese gesamte Idee, ja, wir müssen ja dein Alter feststellen können und
damit letztendlich die Tür zu öffnen.
Altersnachweise werden mit Ausweisdokumenten gemacht.
Wenn du das irgendwie verpflichtend einziehst,
dann nimmst du diesen gesamten Grundsatz der pseudonymen,
anonymen Nutzung des Internets raus Und hast wirklich ein Problem biblischen
Ausmaßes geschaffen, weil es eben,
Alter müssen nicht nur die Kinder nachweisen, die dann an der Altersprüfung
scheitern, sondern jede.
Und da schaffst du dir ein Problemchen, was du wirklich...
Da kannst du mal von einem Markthemmnis reden, weil das kriegen die US-Anbieter auch noch hin.
Da werden die sich freuen, wenn du denen demnächst dann noch deinen Ausweis
zeigen musst für deinen TikTok oder für dein Instagram oder sonst was Profil,
damit sie endlich das Problem los sind, dass da irgendwelche Bots hochgezwungen werden.
Also es ist, das ist aus keinem Guss, das ist einfach nur kopflos, was da abgeht.
Und in das gleiche Horn bläst ja dann die JMSTV-Novelle, der Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag,
der wird alle paar Jahre mal neu geschrieben.
Und da haben sie jetzt gesagt, pass auf, wir wollen jetzt einen Pornofilter
fürs Betriebssystem haben.
Ja, das war ja etwas, wo wir auch schon vor einiger Zeit drüber gesprochen haben,
dass wir gesagt haben, naja, wenn die irgendwann mal auf den Trichter kommen,
dass ihre Chatkontrolle nicht in Signal, WhatsApp oder Telegram.
Was benutzen die Leute, Matrix rein muss, sondern in Android,
iOS, Windows, macOS, Linux, dann hast du den Spaß.
Und das hat jetzt die, hat MSTV-Novelle sagt, sie möchten bitte,
wer jetzt dann einen Computer kauft, dann sollen die Eltern mit einem Klick
das Gerät in einen Lockdown-Child-Safe-Modus versetzen können.
Außerdem soll die Medienaufsichting es einfacher Netzsperren verhängen können,
weil wenn sie jetzt irgendwie eine Seite sperren und die Seite holt sich eine
andere Domain, ist sie wieder erreichbar.
Damit haben halt irgendwie verschiedene Pornoseiten ihr Geschäftsmodell aufrechterhalten,
obwohl es irgendwelche Unglücklichkeiten gab bei der Altersprüfung,
die da irgendwie nicht den Vorgaben entsprach.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, außerdem wollen sie es jetzt auch noch einfacher
haben, Geldflüsse abzudrehen, dass du dann eben sagen kannst,
hier, die Pornoseite, die verdient Geld, der drehen wir jetzt den Hahn ab,
ja, weil sie sich nicht an unsere Regeln hält.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, ja.
Die Altersverifikation selber überlassen sie dann der EU, klar,
da kann jetzt nicht irgendwie der Jugendmedienschutz, das ist ja so ein,
das ist ja quasi, er wird ja aus den, von den Ländern verhandelt,
Er empfiehlt die Medienaufsicht, dass die Seiten die Ausweise der Besucherinnen
kontrollieren oder das Alter per biometrischer Gesichtserkennung schätzen sollen.
Völlig normale Einlassung von irgendwelchen Ministerpräsidentinnen oder was,
die jetzt gesagt haben, das größte Problem,
was wir hier gerade für uns sehen, ist der Jugendschutz im Internet.
Und deswegen wollen wir am besten jetzt biometrische AI-Schätzungen machen,
dass die Leute ein Selfie hochladen, bevor sie eine Pornoseite besuchen dürfen.
Damit wir gucken können, ob die alt genug sind. Und dann hast du demnächst irgendwelche
Kinder, die sich ein Bart ankleben, damit sie ein bisschen, sag ich mal,
autodidaktisch sich der Aufklärung nähern können.
Ja, oder einfach ein anderes Foto hochhalten. Also es wird sicherlich total super funktionieren.
Absurd. Tritt ab 1. Dezember 2027 in Kraft, ja.
Und dann wirst du demnächst, dann muss, wenn dir jemand einen Computer verkauft,
muss ein Knopf dran sein,
Kinderschutzmodus. Da haben wir wieder was Feines geschaffen, ja.
Weil ja Apple das nicht längst schon alles hat, ja. Weil du ja nicht heute schon,
ich weiß nicht, was es da für Screentime, Überwachung, sonst was Möglichkeiten gibt.
Gibt's.
Das ist ja alles schon drin, ja, für die ganzen Helikopter-Eltern,
dass sie, aber nein, das kann ja nicht sein, da müssen sich jetzt Leute hinsetzen
und wieder irgendeinen Quatsch zusammenschreiben.
So sieht's aus. So, machen wir weiter?
Jo, machen wir weiter. Machen wir das auch durch? Was haben wir noch?
Ach, wir haben mal wieder ein schönes Leak, ein Forschungsleak.
Also nicht ein Leak in der Forschung, sondern ein Leak durch Forschung.
WhatsApp wurde von Forschern der Universität Wien ein wenig unter die Lupe genommen.
Das wohl auch schon seit längerem, also Meta hat von denen schon häufiger gehört,
schon über ein Jahr haben die da irgendwie angeklopft und man gesagt,
Leute, ihr habt da irgendwie offensichtlich ein paar Schwachstellen.
Das hat Meta, wie man das eben so macht, erstmal ignoriert und naja,
dann haben die gesagt, na gut, dann forschen wir hier einfach mal weiter und haben,
verschiedene Schwachstellen im Verschlüsselungsmodell von WhatsApp entdeckt
und auch unter Laborbedingungen austesten können.
Und siehe da, es ist ihnen gelungen, an ein paar Account-Daten zu gelangen.
Und wie viele? Alle!
Was ich,
Für eine ganz signifikante Zahl halte. Konkret ist das dann die Zahl 3,5 Milliarden
Accounts, das ist also ungefähr so die Userbase von WhatsApp,
das muss nicht zwingend jetzt in Personen 1 zu 1 umzurechnen sein,
aber so viele Accounts gibt es, da sind sicher auch eine ganze Menge Bots und
Doppelte dabei, pipapo.
Aber dieses vollständige Mitgliederverzeichnis konnte also von diesen Wiener
Forschern heruntergeladen werden.
Dann musste sich auch Meta mal dazu verhalten und hat gesagt,
sorry, tut uns leid und so weiter, aber ist ja nichts passiert,
war ja nur Forschung und so weiter.
Also ist jetzt nicht in the wild, sondern das war jetzt wirklich eine reine
akademische Untersuchung, die aber eben sehr erfolgreich war.
Ja, das ist natürlich alles mal wieder sehr peinlich und wird sicherlich weitgehend
konsequenzfrei bleiben.
Allerdings haben dann die Forscher sich auch mal ein paar Daten angeschaut und
so ein bisschen statistisch ausgewertet, um einfach auch mal einschätzen zu
können, was jetzt hier quasi das potenzielle Missbrauchspotenzial gewesen wäre.
Und ein paar interessante Informationen kann man vielleicht mal erwähnen unter anderem.
Also sie haben herausgeforscht, woher die Accounts stammen und es gab wohl rund
2,3 Millionen aktive WhatsApp-Accounts in China, 60 Millionen im Iran,
1,6 Millionen in Myanmar und irgendwie sogar 5 in Nordkorea,
wo allerdings WhatsApp überall verboten war.
Ja, also offensichtlich ist es doch einigen gelungen, hier Accounts zu machen,
wobei auch hier weiß man wieder nicht, sind das jetzt irgendwie Personen,
sind das irgendwie Bots, die hier betrieben werden, sicherlich eine Mischung aus beidem.
Dann haben sie sich auch mal so die Profile angeschaut, was denn da nun eigentlich
so drin steht und festgestellt, dass so bei gut 30 Prozent der Usern in diesen
Profilen allerlei Dinge preisgegeben werden.
Also die Leute schreiben ihre politischen Einstellungen da rein,
sexuelle oder religiöse Orientierung, teilweise Bekenntnisse zu Drogenmissbrauch
oder dass sie irgendwie auch einfach im Drogenhandel tätig sind.
Also auch das gibt es.
Angaben zum Arbeitsplatz, Hyperlinks auf Profile in sozialen Netzwerken,
wie auch Tinder oder Onlyfans.
E-Mail-Adressen waren natürlich auch dabei, wo dann auch so Adressen von bund.de,
state.gov und .mil Adressen auch zu finden war.
Also wenn man das irgendwie alles strategisch vorliegen hat und analysiert,
dann ergibt das natürlich schon ein sehr reichhaltiges Menü für Leute,
die ein bisschen mehr wissen wollen.
Genau und dann natürlich auch so Metadaten wie wann wurde denn hier das letzte
Mal eine Änderung am Profil vorgenommen und last but not least Profilfotos.
Also wir haben also allein die Profilbilder, die sie dort haben,
laden können, das waren mal so eben 3,8 Terabyte an Daten.
Da haben sie dann mal so eine halbe Million der Bilder genommen und eine zufällige
Stichprobe gemacht, also eine Bildanalyse rüber laufen lassen und festgestellt,
dass gut bei zwei Dritteln da ein menschliches Gesicht war.
Da weiß man jetzt nicht, wie viele AI-generierte Avatare darunter sind,
aber wir können, glaube ich, gut davon ausgehen, dass viele Leute dann halt
auch einfach wirklich ihre eigene Fresse dort haben.
Ja, und das ist halt einfach mal alles von außen zugänglich gewesen.
Ja, das ist ja wirklich das Faszinierende daran, dass man würde erwarten,
dass WhatsApp irgendetwas dagegen unternimmt, dass man diese Daten einfach scrapen kann.
Es ist ja völlig klar, grundsätzlich muss ja das Teilnehmerverzeichnis von WhatsApp
irgendwie für Nutzerinnen zugänglich sein, damit du weißt, wen du über WhatsApp erreichen kannst.
Also wenn du eine Telefonnummer, du kannst jetzt dein WhatsApp aufmachen und
sagen, ich möchte einer Telefonnummer eine WhatsApp-Nachricht schreiben und
dann wird WhatsApp dir antworten müssen, ob du diese Telefonnummer bei WhatsApp erreichst oder nicht.
Das heißt grundsätzlich kann jede Nutzerin, jede andere Nutzerin in WhatsApp
zumindest herausfinden, ob sie WhatsApp nutzt oder nicht.
Jetzt gibt es unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, wie du das machst,
ja, dann bei Signal, das haben wir ja vor ein paar Jahren gesagt,
da gibst du halt Teile der Nummer hin, kriegst andere Teile zurück oder so,
damit Signal nicht weiß, wen du jetzt genau abgefragt hast oder so,
das heißt, du kriegst immer eine ausreichend große Antwort oder sowas.
Hier sind diese Leute hingegangen und haben gesagt, okay,
du kannst die haben von ein und derselben Adresse, also von einer bekannten
Adresse der Uni Wien, wo sie auch die Abuse-Kontaktdaten eingetragen hatten,
waren sie in der Lage, 7000 Telefonnummern pro Sekunde abzugleichen,
ohne dass Meta da irgendetwas gegen macht.
Und dann die Profildaten dazu und die Schlüssel, also die Crypto-Keys,
da konnten sie so 2.000 bis 3.000 Abfragen pro Sekunde machen.
Und die Profilfotos waren dann auf dem HTTP-Server, der 5.500 Bilder pro Sekunde
in hoher Auflösung geliefert hat.
Das heißt, da waren einfach überhaupt keine Limits, diese Sachen zurückzugreifen.
Du könntest ja sagen, okay, du musst als Nutzerin authentifiziert sein und du
darfst als Nutzerin, keine Ahnung.
So und so viele Abfragen machen. Von mir aus auch tausend am Tag oder so.
Irgendeine, was noch realistischer Nutzung entsprechen würde.
Aber die waren eben in der Lage,
in einer überschaubaren Zeit dreieinhalb Milliarden Abfragen zu machen.
Und die Herausforderung, die ihnen eigentlich bei diesem Scraping und das Einzige,
was noch bestand, ist, dass sie limitieren mussten, dass sie nicht alle möglichen
Telefonnummern nehmen, sondern ein bisschen klug konstruieren.
Also beispielsweise, wenn du jetzt den deutschen Raum scrapen würdest,
wärst du schlecht beraten, wie viele Stellen haben Handynummern?
11 bis 15 oder sowas.
15 ist das Maximum mit Ländercode.
Okay, 11 bis 15, gut. Dann geht es aber schon los, den Ländercode kannst du
ja sparen, weil du weißt, der ist 49.
Also die Anzahl Ländercodes, diese ersten beiden Ziffern, da wären ja theoretisch,
weiß ich nicht, wie viele Möglichkeiten, die es da gäbe.
Wahrscheinlich 9 hoch 2 Möglichkeiten. Es gibt aber nicht so viele Ländercodes,
die vergeben sind, also nimmst du nur die.
Dann kannst du weitermachen. In Deutschland kommen danach dann 157,
177 und so weiter, aber viele, viele andere Nummern nicht.
Das heißt, du nimmst natürlich nur die vergebenen, von Mobilfunknetzen genutzten Vorwahlen.
0157, 0177, 0178, 0172, 0171.
Und dann kommen dahinter halt Ziffernketten, dann nimmst du halt nur die.
Das heißt, du hast den Raum von 11 bis 15 Zahlen, also 10 hoch 15 reduziert
auf 10 hoch 9 oder was auch immer.
Also quasi du reduzierst den Raum, den du da scrapest, müsste man jetzt nochmal
genau matematisch, aber so ungefähr ist die Idee.
Und dann kannst du halt 7000 pro Sekunde abfragen und dann hast du irgendwann
einen überschaubaren Raum und das ist denen jetzt hier gelungen,
nicht nur mit Deutschland, nicht nur mit Österreich, sondern dann eben auch
am Ende mit der gesamten Welt.
Und das ist dann schon überraschend, dass das Meta da keinen Schutz hat.
Also spätestens wenn eine IP-Adresse...
Innerhalb von einer Minute, was ist das denn dann,
7000 mal 60, sehr, sehr viele Kontakte abgefragt hat,
inklusive Bildern, dann würdest du ja erwarten, dass wenigstens mal ein Rate-Limit-Alert
oder mal so ein bisschen eine Stunde im Abklingbecken passiert oder so.
Also irgendetwas gegen dieses Scraping unternommen wird, das ist hier nicht erkennbar.
Zumal sie dann auch noch, sie konnten ja die öffentlichen Schlüssel runterladen,
das heißt dadurch würdest du,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche, holst du ein neues Gerät, hast du einen neuen Schlüssel,
das heißt du könntest jetzt quasi dann korrelieren, wann Leute neue Geräte haben,
die konnten außerdem herausfinden, wie viele Geräte für eine Telefonnummer registriert sind,
also ob du da noch irgendwelche, also das ist schon alles.
Und nicht nur das, sie haben auch teilweise festgestellt, dass obwohl da mehrere
Geräte waren, dass die dann teilweise identische Schlüssel hatten,
was eigentlich in dem Verschlüsselungsverfahren so nicht vorkommen sollte.
Also das weist also auch noch auf ein paar Implementations Schwächen hin,
entweder in der Krypto selber oder im Ausfall.
Bei dem Lieblingslieger-Intercept. Bei dem Lawful-Intercept.
Ja, wenn da auf einmal noch ein Gerät mit dem gleichen Schlüssel...
Oniswaki Malipons, sag ich dazu nur. Tja, ja. Na gut.
Kudos auf jeden Fall an die Forscher aus der Uni Wien, die haben da auf jeden
Fall ganze Arbeit geleistet.
Gibt es auch ein schönes GitHub-Repo, nicht mit den, nicht mit dem Scraper selber,
aber der ist glaube ich auch trivial, aber zum Beispiel der Artikel und die
Auswertungen und so weiter.
Ist überraschend. Also man hätte gedacht, dass WhatsApp sich da ein bisschen
mehr drum kümmert um sowas.
Das ist alles brüchig.
Letzte Meldung.
Ja, wir haben seit 2022 hier das regelmäßig behandelt.
Da gab es eine Hausdurchsuchung des freien Radios Dreieckland in Freiburg.
Das Radio Dreieckland ist mit seinen Redaktionsräumen oder mit seinem Sendestudio
oder wie auch immer man das dann nennen kann,
Seine Niederlassung ist unweit des CCC Freiburg und das Radio Dreieckland hat
damals berichtet über den Fall von Indymedia links unten.
Wir hatten das behandelt, das war eine Webseite unter einer Subdomain von indymedia.org,
links unten genannt, weil Freiburg sich links unten in Deutschland befindet.
Und dort hat sich über die Jahre ein Forum ergeben,
wo gerne mal von radikalen linken Gruppen Verlautbarungen oder auch Bekennerschreiben
veröffentlicht wurden.
Und dann hat das Innenministerium, muss es ja gemacht haben,
sich irgendwann dazu durchgerungen, diese Webseite zu verbieten.
Und zwar hat sie das getan, indem sie die Betreiberinnen der Webseite zu einer
kriminellen Vereinigung anbieten.
Benannt hat und dann diese Vereinigung, diese Betreibervereinigung verboten
hat und daraus gesagt hat, okay, damit wird jetzt dieses Forum,
der Betrieb dieses Forums verboten, was insgesamt schon enorm absurdes Vorkommnis ist,
welches wir ebenfalls behandelt haben, welches auch außerdem in Vorträgen auf
dem CCC-Kongress behandelt wurde, die wir auch nochmal verlinken.
Jetzt kommt Gradio Dreieckland, behandelt
diesen Fall im Rahmen seiner journalistischen Tätigkeit und verlinkt dabei auf
ein irgendwo im Internet gehostetes Backup von dieser Seite, die ja jetzt weg war.
Und in Konsequenz des Verlinkens dieses Backups dieser Seite,
das unter anderem, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, auch in einem Tweet des Bundesamtes
für Verfassungsschutz ebenfalls verlinkt war,
findet dann eine Durchsuchung der Redaktionsräume dieses freien Radios statt.
Absurd.
Absurd. Und dagegen sind die dann natürlich vorgegangen, erstens,
dass sie überhaupt etwas Falsches getan hätten, indem sie hier auf ein öffentlich
zugängliches Archiv, das sie nicht betreiben,
linken im Rahmen ihrer redaktionellen journalistischen Tätigkeit,
dass das überhaupt ein Problem wäre, das ist ja schon mal ein Thema.
Dann aber, dass eine Durchsuchung dieser Redaktionsräume stattfindet,
das ist ja auch nochmal ein Thema.
Deswegen haben sie natürlich dagegen geklagt und am Oberlandesgericht Stuttgart
wurde gesagt, nee, das ist völlig in Ordnung, dass bei euch die Hausdurchsuchung stattgefunden hat.
Also sind sie mit der GFF vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht gegangen und das
Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, Selbstverständlich war die Durchsuchung der Wohnung
eines Redakteurs, der noch on top,
selbstverständlich war diese Wohnungsdurchsuchung nicht in Ordnung.
Bei dem Artikel, der diesen Link platziert hatte.
Und gleichzeitig sagen sie, es gab keine plausiblen Gründe, warum man bei diesem
Menschen die Wohnung durchsucht hat.
Und meine, dass sie sich ebenfalls darüber äußern, dass es natürlich auch keine
plausiblen Gründe überhaupt für Untersuchungen in den Redaktionsräumen gab.
Es geht also spezifisch erstmal um die Wohnungsdurchsuchung.
Aber meine ich auch, dass quasi darin auch gesagt wird, Durchsuchungen in Redaktionsräumen
und Wohnräumen von Journalistinnen gefährden das Redaktionsgeheimnis und den Quellenschutz,
sagt jetzt der Jurist David Werdermann, der das Verfahren für die GFF koordiniert hat.
Und das Verfassungsgericht watscht also jetzt das Oberlandesgericht ab und sagt,
das ist keine verfassungsrechtlich tragfähige Darlegung des Tatverdachts vorgelegt,
der irgendwie diesen Eingriff in die Presse- und Rundfunkfreiheit und in die
Privatsphäre gerechtfertigt hätte.
Schocker.
Also es ist schon absurd. Nochmal, es ging hier jetzt spezifisch bei dem Verfahren um die,
Durchsuchung,
der Privatwohnung. Ich hatte das, vor allem nochmal persönlich auch allein schon
die Durchsuchung der Redaktionsräume.
Geärgert.
Damit sagen sie eben ja, der Schutzbereich der Pressefreiheit gilt auch für
Wohnungen und journalistische Kommunikationsmittel.
Das ist insgesamt einfach so ein absurdes Vorkommnis gewesen und ich finde es
halt wirklich übel, dass man sowas überhaupt diskutieren muss.
Also noch dazu dieser Anlass hier.
Und ja, du musst natürlich, ist das eine, also dieser Fall selber ist absurd,
aber auch die Signalwirkung, die so etwas hat, dass du, wenn man in der Zeitung liest, ach so,
wenn die Polizei sich das überlegt oder die Staatsanwaltschaft sich das überlegt,
dann durchsuchen die halt einfach mal Redaktionsräume und Privatwohnungen von
Journalistinnen für irgendwelche Gingalizien.
Wie willst du denn dann noch irgendwie überhaupt einer Journalistin vertrauen können?
Ja, selbst wenn du auf der individuellen Ebene das Vertrauen hast,
weißt du halt nicht, ob der nicht morgen die Tür eingetreten wird und alles rausgetragen wird.
Noch dazu gab es ja in diesem Falle, muss man ganz klar sagen,
ich meine, die haben auf ein öffentliches Archiv gelingt, auf das selbst der
Bundesverfassungsschutz gelingt hat.
Also absurd. Es gab also überhaupt keine.
Kein Ermittlungsversprechen. Was willst du denn da herausfinden?
Immerhin werden wir dann unsere Genugtuung haben, wenn alle Verantwortlichen
für diesen Fuck-up dann selbstverständlich zurücktreten werden und die Konzerne da ausziehen werden.
Drei Jahre lang jetzt da irgendwie so einen Menschen terrorisiert,
der letztendlich da ein freies Radio macht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da jetzt das große Kapital hinter steckt,
hinter dieser ganzen Initiative.
Ja und vor allem sein Vergehen, er hat einen Domainnamen ins Internet geschrieben.
Er war noch nicht mal der Erste, der es getan hat. Das ist völlig absurd.
Das war ein Missbrauch, ein erkennbarer Missbrauch der Möglichkeiten,
mit denen wir Strafverfolgungsbehörden im Extremfall zur Verfolgung schwerer
Straftaten ausstatten.
Hier um eine politische Gruppierung, angebliche politische Gruppierung,
dieses Kollektiv, dass die Webseite, beschuldigt wird, diese Webseite betrieben zu haben,
dass er überhaupt keine Schuld daran trägt, was die Inhalte ist,
weil eine Open-Posting-Seite, das ist ja das Ding, die haben ja Open-Posting zugelassen.
Also es ist alles von vorne bis hinten absolut absurd und dann auch noch ein
Redakteur, der den Fall behandelt, natürlich kritisch darüber berichtet,
was die Staatsanwaltschaft und die Polizei da getan haben in diesem Kontext.
Und das ist doch das, was hier passieren sollte, dass diese journalistische
Berichterstattung eingeschränkt werden sollte oder eingeschüchtert werden sollte.
Und das ist schon auch...
Natürlich juristisch korrekt, dass wir darüber eben sprechen,
über das war eine verfassungswidrige Maßnahme, die da stattgefunden hat,
aber die mal in den Kontext zu setzen, warum hat die denn stattgefunden?
Warum hat denn irgendjemand in Baden-Württemberg gedacht, heute ist das Beste,
was die Polizei machen kann, bei diesen Redaktionsräumen reinmarschieren?
Das war ja jetzt nicht irgendwie eine angemessene strafrechtliche Priorisierung,
um Schaden vom Land abzuwenden.
Das war ein absoluter Missbrauch.
Insofern bleibt er natürlich ohne jegliche Konsequenzen. und alle dürfen weitermachen.
So sieht's aus.
Damit sind wir am Ende für der heutigen Sendung.
Genau, damit sind wir am Ende. Wenn die anderen weitermachen, hören wir jetzt auf.
Ist ja nichts zu ertragen. Ja, dann mache ich am Ende nochmal was,
was ich selten genug tue, Aber was vielleicht auch mal erwähnt werden sollte,
20 Jahre Meta-Ebene gibt es vor allem deshalb, weil viele von euch sich bereit
erklärt haben, die Meta-Ebene auch finanziell zu unterstützen.
Der ganze Ablauf hier ist nicht gerade kostenfrei, kann man nicht sagen.
Hat sich auch nicht unbedingt viel verbessert. Es muss allerlei investiert werden
in Server. Es gibt jetzt auch noch ein Geschenk von mir.
Das wird glaube ich für diese Sendung noch nicht greifen, aber das kommt.
Aber ich werde jetzt einen Serverumzug machen und dann zurückgehen.
Blasen wir auch mal mit 10 Gigabit ins Internet und nicht nur mit diesem bescheidenen
Gigabit, was immer dazu führt, dass immer alle so Download-Probleme haben. Ist das Cloudflare?
Nee, aber ich nehme sozusagen die Gelegenheit wahr, da mal ein Upgrade vorzunehmen.
Genau, aber daher...
Aber wieso? Es laden doch eh alle nur über Kupfer runter, da brauchst du doch
jetzt nicht mehr Bandbreite.
Ich weiß nicht, also so wie sie sich beklagen, habe ich das Gefühl,
die haben alle schon Glasfaser.
Der ist ja auch absolut berechtigt und das ist kein Zustand,
dass jetzt hier irgendwie jedes Mal die Büchse in die Knie geht.
Anyway, ich wäre euch auf jeden Fall sehr dankbar, wenn ihr mal überlegen könntet,
ob ihr entweder eine bereits bestehende Unterstützungszahlung an die Metaebene,
Inflationsausgleich anpassen könntet. Oder überhaupt mal zu erwägen,
die Mitte-Ebene regelmäßig zu unterstützen, denn das ist das,
was hier den ganzen Apparat am Leben erhält.
Das ist das, was uns die Freiheit gibt, hier auch ungerichtet immer wieder auf
die Welt zu schauen, alle möglichen Dinge zu verfolgen.
Das ist das, was uns die Möglichkeit gibt, all diese ganzen merkwürdigen Paywall
versteckten Artikel zu lesen, um Hintergründe zu verstehen.
Das ist das, was uns die Gelegenheit gibt, hier auch zahlreiche Hosting-Dienste
und andere Services in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Und ja, was uns in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich auch eine Freiheit erkauft,
so recherchieren zu können und so Sendungen planen und durchführen zu können.
Ohne euch zum Beginn, Mitte und Ende der Sendung mit Produkthinweisen zu versorgen.
Genau. Da müsst ihr nur ab und zu mal Linus Amazon Affiliate Links ertragen.
Überlegt mal, was ihr da für ein Geld spart. Dadurch, dass wir euch hier nicht
die ganze Zeit heizdecken und Hundefutter andrehen. Da müsst ihr auch mal überlegen.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Das könnt ihr einfach mal reinvestieren, dieses gesparte Geld.
Das Geld gibt er jetzt uns. Weil wir wollen nämlich gerne Heizdecken und Hundefutter kaufen.
Nee, also ich habe das ja auch in meinem 20-Jahre-Meter-Ebene-Blogpost auch nochmal erklärt.
Werbung ist hier einfach keine Option, auch wenn ich verstehen kann,
dass das manche machen, wenn man sich anguckt, was da teilweise für ein Geld
für bezahlt wird von den Werbetreibenden, dann ist das natürlich alles sehr
verlockend, aber ich will trotzdem nicht.
Nee, haben wir ja glaube ich schon oft genug dargestellt, dass das für uns nicht möglich ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das oft genug dargestellt haben, aber ich finde so einmal
im Jahr kann man das schon mal fallen lassen.
Einmal im Jahr kann man das erwähnen.
Genau, ansonsten nerven wir euch nämlich auch nicht damit. Wir wollen auch keine
Likes, keine Subscribes wollen wir schon. Du willst geliked werden?
Likes, Subscribe, Glocke, 5 Sterne bei Spotify.
Gibt's nicht.
Wer es schafft, also wer es schafft bei uns fünf Sterne, für uns fünf Sterne
bei Spotify, der muss nicht bezahlen.
Aber natürlich hilft es,
Also die eine Sache ist, die Meta-Ebene finanziell zu unterstützen,
damit wir das machen können und Tim das machen kann. CAE und Freakshow und,
Logbuch und Raumzeit. Raumzeit kommt wieder mehr.
Genau.
Forschergeist ist vorbei, ne?
Forschergeist ist erstmal so auf Eis gelegt. Da muss ich halt irgendwie ein
Modell finden, wie man das redaktionell abbilden kann.
Ich fahre jetzt langsam wieder hoch, jetzt kommt erstmal Raumzeit dran und mal
schauen, dass ich auch mal wieder an den CAE raushaue.
Aber wichtig ist vor allem, dass wir jetzt die regelmäßigen Sendungen machen.
Friekschuh, UKW, LNP, das läuft auf jeden Fall und das ist auch schon mal eine
ganze Menge Holz, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Wie es halt funktioniert und klappt und machbar ist.
Und die eine Möglichkeit ist, das finanziell zu unterstützen,
dass das alles passieren kann.
Die andere Wirklichkeit ist natürlich, dafür zu sorgen, dass es mehr Leute hören,
die es dann finanziell unterstützen und insofern ist die Empfehlung.
Preiset uns, preiset uns, dann geht es euch besser. So Leute,
und jetzt lassen wir euch auch schon wieder in Ruhe.
Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung über
all die Jahre und jetzt schreiten wir in die dritte Dekade. Goldene 20er sind jetzt vorbei.
Das war's. Das war die Golden 20er.
Bin mal gespannt, wie lange du das schaffst. Also da werde ich dich jetzt dran
erinnern, wenn du nächste Woche wieder anfängst mit deinen Goldenen 20ern. Was ist das?
Vorbei. Das waren jetzt die 20 Jahre, die waren golden und jetzt gucken wir mal, was kommt.
Okay.
Bis bald, Leute. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao. Danke, Tim.